in the last video we had this rectangle
and we use a triple integral to figure
out its volume and I know you and you
were probably thinking well I could have
just used my basic geometry to figure
out to multiply the height times the
width times the depth and that's true
because this was a constant valued
function and then even once we evaluated
when once we integrated with respect to
Z we ended up with a double integral
which is exactly what you would have
done within the last several videos when
we just learned the volume under a
surface but then we added a twist at the
end of the video we said fine everything
you could have figured out the volume
within this rectangular domain I guess
very straight forward using things you
already knew but what if our goal was
not to figure out the volume our goal
was to figure out the mass of this
volume and even more the mass the the
material that we're taking the volume of
whether it's you know volume of gas or
volume of some solid that it's density
is not constant so now the mass becomes
kind of I don't know interesting to
calculate and so what we defined we
defined a made enca T function and Rho
this P looking thing with a curvy bottom
that was that gives us the density at
any given point and at the end of the
last video we said well what is mass
mass is just density times volume or you
could always you could view another way
density is the same thing as mass
divided by volume so the mass around a
very very small point and we call that D
mass the differential of the mass is
going to equal the density at that point
or the rough density at exactly that
point times the volume differential
around that point right times the volume
of this little small cube and then we as
we saw it on the last video if you're
using rectangular coordinates this
volume differential could just be the X
distance times the Y distance times the
Z's distance so what if we wanted the
density was that our density function is
defined to be XY and Z and we wanted to
figure out the mass of this of this
volume and let's say that our XY and z
coordinates their values let's say
they're in meters and let's say this
density is in kilograms per meter cubed
so our answer was going to be in
kilograms if that
case and those are kind of the
traditional SI units so let's figure out
the mass of this variably dense volume
so all we do is we have the same
integral up here so the mass it for the
the differential of mass is going to be
this value so let's write that down
so it's let me it is X I want to make
sure I don't want a space X Y Z times
and I'm going to integrate with respect
to DX DZ first but you could do that you
could actually switch the order maybe
we'll do that in the next video we'll do
DZ first then we'll do dy then we'll do
DX and then we just define so this is
this is once again this is just the mass
at any you know small differential of
volume and if we integrate with Z first
we said Z goes from what the Vaught the
boundaries on Z were 0 to 2 0 to 2 the
boundaries on Y where 0 to 4 and the
boundary is on X X went from 0 to 3 0 to
3 and how do we evaluate this well what
is the antiderivative of we're
integrating with respect to Z first so
what's the antiderivative of X Y Z with
respect to Z well it's let's see this is
just a constant so it'll be X Y Z
squared over 2 right yeah that's right
and then we'll evaluate that from 2 to 0
and so you get I know I'm going to run
out of space so you're going to get 2
squared which is 4 divided by 2 which is
2 so it's 2 XY 2 XY minus 0 so that's it
so the the evaluate when you evaluate
just this first interval to get 2xy and
now you have the other two integrals
left so I didn't write the other two
integrals down maybe all right now so
then you're left with two integrals
you're left with dy and DX and Y goes
from 0 to 4 and
goes from zero to three I'm definitely
going to run out of space and now you
take the antiderivative of this with
respect to Y so what's the
antiderivative this with respect to Y
let me erase some stuff just so I don't
get too messy
I would I given the very good suggestion
of making it scroll but in this
unfortunate it make it scroll enough
this time so I can delete this stuff I
think oops I deleted some of that but I
you know what I deleted okay so let's
take the antiderivative with respect to
while I'll start it up here where have
space okay so the antiderivative 2xy
with respect to Y is it's y squared over
two twos cancel out so you get XY
squared XY squared and Y goes from zero
to four and then we still have the outer
integral to do X goes from 0 to 3 DX and
when Y is equal to 4 you get 16x 16x and
then when y is zero the whole thing is
zero so you have 16x integrate it from
zero to three DX and that is equal to
what 8x squared 8x squared and if
evaluated from zero to three when it's 3
8 times 9 is 72 and zero times eight is
zero so the mass of our figure the
volume we figured out last time was 24
meters cubed I erased it but if you
watch the last video that's what we
learned
but its mass is 72 kilograms and we did
that by integrating this this three
variable density function this function
of three variables or you can in three
dimensions you can view it as a scalar
field right at any given point there is
a value but not really direction and
that value is a density but we
integrated this scalar field in this
volume so that's kind of the new skill
we learned with the triple integral and
in the next video I'll show you how to
set up a more complicated triple
integrals but the real difficulty with
triple integrals is and then you I think
you'll see that your calculus teacher
will often do this when you're doing
triple integrals unless you have a very
easy figure like this the evaluation
if you actually wanted to analytically
evaluate a triple integral that has more
complicated boundaries or more
complicated you know for for example a
density function the integral gets very
hairy very fast and it's it's often very
difficult or very time-consuming to
evaluate it analytically just using your
you know traditional calculus skill so
you'll you'll see that a lot of calculus
exams when they start doing the triple
integral they just want you to set it up
and they take your if they take your
word for it that you know you've done so
many integrals so far that you could
take the antiderivative and sometimes if
they really want to give you something
more difficult than to say well change
switch the order you know this is the
integral when we're doing with respect
to Z then Y then X we want you to
rewrite this integral when you switch
the order and we will do that in the
next video see you soon